hey what is up everybody it's annamac
here for anime uproar and just when we
thought that one of the most emotional
battles in mha was over horikoshi throws
us another bombshell perhaps literally
but more on that later the aftermath of
shoto vs dobby has had a profound impact
on the heroes and hero students but the
villains are not giving up and all for
one seems to be one step ahead yet again
multiple heroes may be about to die in
the very next chapter so let's talk
about it you guys know how this works if
you enjoy our videos and you want to
support us just leave a quick like and
comment it only takes a second but it
really helps us with that youtube
algorithm and of course subscribing and
hitting that notification bell is a
completely free but very real way of
directly supporting the channel you can
also hit me up on twitter and instagram
at anime opera finally this video will
of course contain boku do hero manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned we start things off
in the aftermath of shoto's epic battle
against dobby and at first it's
confirmed that dobby has in fact been
defeated nevertheless this victory comes
at a very high cost for shoto who has
suffered both physical and emotional
damage kamino is also in ruins
endeavours sidekicks and the other
heroes in the area have suffered serious
injuries but the fact that dobby has
been defeated and secured turns out to
be a huge morale booster for the hero
students and the heroes everyone is
impressed that a ua hero student was
able to defeat the overpowered wielder
of the blue flames the man who
practically destroyed an entire section
of a city and so the other heroes decide
to follow up on shoto's work by giving
it their all in order to crush the nomu
and the other villains the news about
dobby's defeat made it back to the hero
command center where tsukauchi and all
might are monitoring the situation
across all the various battlefields
almighty is clearly proud of shoto's
accomplishment but he is also emotional
because he knows how hard this must have
been for shoto and we really do have to
give a lot of respect to our boy
todoroki not only has he been able to
surpass his limits and awaken his quirk
in ways that we've never seen before but
he was also able to overcome so much
childhood trauma in order to do what had
to be done in regards to dobby shoto has
always been one of my favorite
characters because of his compelling
backstory and his powerful character
development and these last few chapters
really allowed him some time to shine
and i love it tsukauji then asks all
might to inform all the heroes across
all the different battlefields about
shoto's victory and that is when
everyone else learns of this major
development over at the ruins of jakku
hospital where a special facility for
containing gigantomachia has been
erected a bunch of the class 1a and 1b
students are ecstatic to hear that shoto
has won the pro heroes like mount lady
are also fired up when they hear this
news and the hero side is clearly
gaining momentum against the villains on
the back of shoto's victory and this
really is an important thing to think
about in war soldier morale is almost
always a major factor some would even
say the major factor and hearing about a
big victory for your side really will
fire soldiers up and inspire them to
achieve things they never would have
thought possible before they heard the
news famous generals like napoleon
constantly reminded their soldiers of
their past victories in order to inspire
them to repeat those results in the
future and of course if a battle was
being waged on multiple fronts and your
soldiers win on one front you will
immediately tell everyone about the
victory in order to motivate soldiers on
the other fronts to also gain victory
that said some of the villains didn't
quite get the message that the heroes
are winning and one villain in
particular proclaims that the sacrifices
of the heroes will be in vain this is
the villain who was responsible for the
death of midnight and he tells mina and
the other students that this is the time
of liberation and those who stand
against liberation will be run down into
the ground
just like midnight was
mina instantly looks at the villain as
if to say say that one more time mother
but that's when our boy kirishima shows
up kirishima says that everyone has been
evacuated from the area which means that
the heroes can now go all out against
the villains a fierce-looking kirishima
says that todoroki just showed them how
manly he was and now it's time for them
to do their part mina was clearly upset
when the villain mentioned midnight but
kirishima showed up and got her back on
track we gotta remember that when they
were kids mina was the one whom
kirishima looked to for inspiration and
leadership and he himself lacked
confidence
but this time he was the one who kept
her from losing her cool and helped her
stay focused on the mission i honestly
love these two i love their history and
their relationship and i'm a big
minishima shipper we also get to see
that up in the flying ua bakugo is not
even surprised to hear that shoto won
and i'm sure that bakugou will be
looking to one-up shoto at some point
during the war because that's just how
bakugou is meanwhile fat gum and aoyama
are confronted by a villain who can
control plants i guess this guy is a
tartarus skp by the name of kinieda and
he says that he is all for one's latest
assassin having replaced dictator he
tells aoyama that no one has dared to
lie to olfa 1 and lived to tell the tale
implying that aoyama is about to die
aoyama responds by saying thank you in
french for some reason and then the
focus switches to spinner it appears
that spinner was given extra quirks by
all for one including at least one that
allowed him to increase his size until
he's basically a giant
spinner refuses to believe the news that
dobby has lost and he thinks that it's
all just hero propaganda spinner is now
leading a group of villains with mutant
type quirks and his mission appears to
be to retrieve kurogiri spinner also
seems way more angry than usual which
makes me wonder whether the new quirk or
quirks that offer one gave him are also
affecting him mentally on top of
changing him physically but that's
something we'll likely find out later
spinner commands the other villains to
tear down everything that oppressed them
for so long and to destroy the status
quo meanwhile shoji who also has a
mutant type quirk draws inspiration from
todoroki to continue standing his ground
against spinner and his lackeys it looks
like we're about to see an important
fight between shoji and spinner two
characters with mutant type quirks who
both faced discrimination
but who ended up choosing completely
opposite paths in life so this is gonna
be interesting back in camino shoto is
injured but he is conscious and he seems
to be doing well meanwhile one of the
other heroes is wondering how dobby is
even still alive and that is when we see
it a circle of light suddenly begins to
shine in the middle of dobby's chest but
before we can see what happens next we
are transported to the gunga mountain
resort where endeavour and hawks are
confronting all for one i will get back
to the dobby thing very soon but i just
want to cover what happens with all for
one first all for one is trying to
unravel endeavor by mocking him for
sending one of his sons to fight the
other instead of standing up against
dobby himself all for one proclaims that
this refusal to take personal
responsibility for his own actions is
the reason why endeavour cannot win and
the chapter ends as all for one begins
activating a strange quirk combo he
holds out his hand and a different quirk
seems to emerge from each of his fingers
one finger has a flame around it another
has drills a third has curved blades a
fourth has black sludge and a fifth has
like a tiny human face coming out of it
because i guess all for one found a
philosopher's stone from fullmetal
alchemist or something and that is how
the chapter ends with all for one trying
to rattle endeavor mentally before
taking him on in battle and with the
text on the final page declaring that
despite the hero's plan all for one
remains as calm as ever wow this sure
was creepy and all for one really is a
villain that you cannot underestimate i
mean yes he got tricked by aoyama and
the heroes but he doesn't seem concerned
at all and he's always ready with some
sort of backup plan no matter what the
heroes throw his way it's going to be
very interesting to see just what insane
quirk combo all for one is about to
unleash upon the top two pro heroes okay
now back to the dobby glowing chest
thing to me this indicates that all for
one jammed a second quirk into dobby
likely against dobby's will because i do
believe that dobby wanted to beat both
shoto and endeavor using his own quirk
alone the big question is what is this
second quirk is it something that would
allow dabi to recover and keep fighting
or is it the same type of
self-destruction quirk that offer one
had used on lady nagant back in chapter
315 when lady nagant explodes in that
chapter we don't actually see her chest
so we don't know if there was a similar
effect going on we just see that the
rest of her body begins to like glow and
crack right before she explodes it is
possible that this glow in dobby's chest
is the beginning of the self-destruct
quirk activating and if that is the case
then considering the shape that dobby is
in right now i can't picture him
surviving this dobie is in way worse
shape right now than lady nagant was
before the explosion so if he really
explodes right now he will likely die
although he will probably take some
heroes down with him i don't think that
shoto will die after everything he's
just been through but a notable hero
like burn and might even though i
obviously do not want another waifu to
be harmed you come to 9211 ocean view
drive that's my home address and i will
knife fight you horikoshi my man ida is
right there like no offense either but
if i have to choose between you and
bernie i'm choosing vernon what do you
guys think is the light on dobby's chest
a sign that a second quirk is activating
within him or is it something that is
part of his own quirk like maybe his own
quirk is awakening if this is a second
quirk what do you think it is and could
it be
self-destruction definitely share your
thoughts down below because i need to
see some great theories about this being
discussed in the comments since dobby
was already a ticking time bomb due to
his obsession with endeavour and shoto i
wouldn't be surprised if all for one
secretly infused him with
self-destruction but we'll have to wait
and see i am extremely excited to see
what happens next and what kind of
situation deku will walk into once he
finally makes it back to shore for all
we know a bunch of heroes could be dead
by the time deku arrives and that would
absolutely destroy him emotionally but
it would also motivate him to absolutely
crush the villains if you guys enjoyed
this video you know what to do just
leave a quick like and comment it only
takes a second but it really helps me
out and remember that subscribing and
hitting that notification bell is a very
real way of directly supporting the
channel and of course it's completely
free you can also hit me up on twitter
and instagram at animeopror i want to
give a big thank you to all of our anime
outpour patrons for making videos like
this one possible special thank you to
kyle salisbury this man is an absolute
mad lad and a disciple of lord twego
himself and i can't forget all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all other clans including alpha
sigma pate heffa the red-haired fox
hinokami and water the toasted chi corey
mcgowan the fallen chosen orihime wukong
dante tinnell and big buddhist finally
thank you also to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh angel cruz alicia octor bonnie
parks fat boy games kaido might be a
duck alivania and anime s codem if you
guys enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value to you consider
supporting us on patreon as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see space cowboys